when it comes to climate change bill
gates wants people to think of two
numbers
51 billion and zero 51 billion
is the number of tons of greenhouse
gases typically added to the atmosphere
every year because of human activities
zero is the number of tons we need to
get to by 2050
in order to avoid a climate crisis gates
has released a new book
detailing his plan to get to zero tons
called how to avoid a climate disaster
the solutions we have and the
breakthroughs we need his breakdown of
how we get to 51 billion tons of
greenhouse gases each year puts goods
production
as well as generating and transmitting
electricity at the top
the rest is divided among transportation
raising animals forestry
and temperature control systems last
year gates suggested the us should
create a national institutes of energy
innovation to help the country take the
lead in climate change innovation
gates says currently about 7 billion
dollars a year of government money gets
spent on research and development for
energy innovation
compared to 37 billion dollars a year
for medical research
but at the same time he acknowledges
that whatever developments come from the
us
have to be affordable for other
countries to actually implement
and the us accounts for 14 of global
emissions
so even if it managed to get to zero
carbon emissions
there'd still be a long way to go in a
recent interview with forbes
gates says he has put two billion
dollars of his own money towards
companies working towards
zero emissions two of the more
well-known ones he's backed are
impossible foods and beyond meat both
dealing with plant-based meats
his biggest bet has been on terra power
a nuclear power company with a reactor
that uses depleted uranium as fuel
the company had been planning on
building its first reactor in china
but the deal was blocked by the us
government now the plan is to build a
demonstration plant somewhere stateside
and the company received 80 million
dollars to do so from the department of
energy
the other half will come from the
private sector mostly gates himself
he's also created a fund called
breakthrough energy ventures and has
investors such as jeff bezos
vinod khosla john arnold and john dewer
putting in money towards
zero carbon companies gates says he
hopes at the least
his book will get more people talking
about what needs to be done to save the
planet
but a bigger measure of his success is
whether the biden administration takes
up any of his proposals
as official policies